please to have back here on the show
it's been quite some time he's one of
the best it's certainly covering the
collegiate sports landscape with college
football on the horizon and the Oklahoma
State Oh a and kerfuffle is that what
we're calling it there Pat forty of
Yahoo Sports back here on the show how
are you Pat good place to start rich I
guess so
well what is what what are the state of
affairs right now at Oklahoma State
football best you can tell Pat unsettled
they're trying to put on the you know
best face of we've got everything under
control and we're proceeding and the the
eruption from Monday maybe that will
turn out to be the case but I'm not so
this is going to be just an easy one to
gloss over with a quite wooden apology
video from Mike Gundy reading from a
script' the fact of the matter is super
Harvard the running back was leading
returning rusher in the country and kind
of started all this by calling Gundy out
on social media is continuing to monitor
could be on social media it's pretty
extraordinary it's not like he he fired
off warm twist that said okay I better
be quiet and fade into the background
here he's he's continuing to say that
you know the foot is on the pedal and he
said that Gandhi's apology video was a
step in the right direction but you know
I think that there's still some work
that Gundy is gonna have to do to repair
his locker room and and to get people
back hundred percent on his side here
pat forty appreciate the kerfuffle not
that I called you by your your wrong
address Sports Illustrated and senior
writer Pat forty here on the Rich Eisen
show so can you walk me through the
timeline here between the two different
videos the one with Gundy and Hubbard
and then the one that Gundy I guess felt
compelled to make on his own with that
interesting sort of background behind
him
walk me through the timeline best you
can tell that yeah neither of them I
don't think we're cinematic excellence
but you know the first one wasn't I
think very hastily arranged probably a
result of like gun to getting on the
phone with Hubbert and saying what are
you doing man and then talking to the
athletic department saying we got to do
some damage control here
get me a video camera get ubin here I'll
put on an Oklahoma State shirt will say
that so you know we learned something
and let's try to minimize the damage and
that video came out with Hubbert being
the one who was apologetic and contrite
and Gundy just said yeah well that's
next thing I think I've learned a little
something and that didn't wasn't overly
well-received it ended with an awkward
hug and I think that most people thought
that there needed to be a little bit
more to it the vent and that's when
Gundy came back in try number two to
quell this and his words were good in in
the second video it's just the it was
very clear that he was reading it from a
prepared statement and so you know maybe
it needed me that way cuz nobody trusts
him off the cuff I don't know but that
was then Tuesday and now so far on
Wednesday no videos yet from Stillwater
no I guess I know that pat forty here on
the Rich Eisen show from Sports
Illustrated look we're not expecting you
know college coaches to be experts on
politics and things of that nature or or
shocked that a coach might have a
certain political bent and that's
entirely fine this is America it is a
free country that said for for the thing
that I I I want to believe Mike Gundy
cuz I'm an optimist and I believe in the
better nature of everyone for him to say
that Oh a n is an outfit that he had no
idea where they stood on the issue of
black lives matter or or is an issue an
outlet that has no slant no bias it it
really it really strains credulity to be
very honest with you
pat so my question for you here is
moving forward our coaches gonna keep
things to themselves if they believe
it's something that's different or or
what's the lesson here
with Gundy yeah I would I mean I would
say that's probably the case is you know
though my palm is probably not the only
coastal watches away you know I find
yeah finders Network you know I think
the problem yeah is that his his
explanations say you know for him to
come out in April and say what a quality
News Network it is and it's it's fair
and unbiased they just present facts and
then you know six weeks later saying I
didn't know they reported on that I
didn't know they help those Jews that's
overly credible but I would think if I
were a coach that yeah I would be I
would be pretty hesitant at least to the
hourly espousing much of any political
views at this point you know I think
it's been great to see some of the
activism and some of the stances from a
lot of coaches out there in regards to
the the black lives matter movement
regards to police brutality and in
regards to the racial situation in
America today and I think those are all
good things but I also think that
coaches who it may not be the most
politically savvy of all people can
probably get themselves in more trouble
to make it do good with some of the
things they say so what about the other
side these the moral of the story for
for the athlete because we're also
seeing that Chris toil the longtime
strength coach at Iowa is no longer
there anymore after past players we're
talking about being made to feel
uncomfortable by some of his stances on
the subjects of the day he's now gone
and and he was as firmly ensconced in
the Iowa program as anybody else not
named Ference I guess and and you see
what what Hubbard what Chabot Hubbard
had to say on this subject certainly got
gun DS attention do you think that there
is a possibility of players flexing some
muscle here to get
some changes that they never thought
existed no doubt about it
we're seeing it happen in real time you
know it started Florida State some
players called out the new coach there
Mike Norvell on a statement that he made
there was an exaggeration of his
communication with the players and then
go from there count yet two they kind of
just avalanches of criticism of Chris
Doyle at Iowa and that result of
intangible change he's out after being
the right-hand man
to Kirk Ferentz there and and now
continuing with the situation Oklahoma
State I think players around the country
are looking around saying geez we you
know we don't have to just keep quiet
about everything you know that we are
allowed to speak up and we are allowed
to have opinions and we're allowed at
least to call out truths as we see them
and that's one thing that I think we're
seeing here is like you know that the
old line was always keep it in-house
don't say anything that doesn't reflect
well on the team well now it's like you
know what if we've got bad things going
on in our program and we know it we're
gonna say it and I think that's going to
let lead to a new level of
accountability for coaches that you
can't act one way in public and then
behind closed doors of your practice
facility be a tyrant be a bully be in
any way you know insensitive to your
players either racial situation
socioeconomic polite whatever the case
may be so I think that there is
absolutely a new a new voice in the new
power behind the voice for athletes Pat
forty here on the Rich Eisen show from
Sports Illustrated senior writer so that
said I had my fun with Albert Brewer
earlier on the show as you know I'm a
Michigan guy and he's an Ohio State guy
I told him next time he comes on he's
gonna have to sign the Rich Eisen show
pledge that we're not we're not looking
at as a waiver it's a pledge his retort
was you know before I answer you should
make sure that that there's no liability
concerns that equal liability concerns
in your own house so I don't know is
that is that gonna be standard across
the the landscape for for players to
return
Pat what's this all about well you know
it wouldn't shock me if there's a lot of
school some some other schools are doing
it yeah and and it wouldn't surprise me
if a bunch more decide you know by July
1st say we better have these pledges up
and running and then call them pledges
even though you know they're clearly
something more than that you know hi I
am sure athletic directors university
presidents and their legal counsel are
all on eggshells saying we are possibly
walking into you know a liability
firestorm here if bringing back athletes
doesn't go right you know they're the
Canaries in the coal mine on this before
the general student population returns
most of them are basically feeling
beholden to come back as opposed to
being invited to come back even though
that's the wording on this and this is
all for voluntary but we know how that
works and so I think that they're gonna
look to protect themselves in waterful
whatever form or fashion they can with
you know those waivers or other signed
documents just to somewhat shift some of
the burden onto the athletes and off of
the school if things do not go well so
what do you think happens here Pat um
you know in the University of Houston
had a bit of an outbreak and then shut
things down um you know I spoke to to
Brian Kelly about a month ago and he
said that you know that they're gonna
put health and protocol issues in front
of parents to let folks know what's
going on and he still didn't even know
that was about a month ago I mean what
do you what do you what do you have for
me do you think on on on whether this is
a go and everybody's gonna you know
Michigan's actually just used my alma
mater as an example is gonna get on a
plane and do open the season on time
maybe with no fans in the stands at
Washington but that's actually gonna
happen like a Big Ten at pac-12 contest
is gonna happen on time and and and all
that you think that's the case right now
this thing has wavered back and forth a
couple of times rich
I mean in the late April first half of
May we're like there's no way football
season starting on time and then all of
a sudden you know things started to look
a little better from a National Health
Outlook and people started talking a
much more optimistic game and then it
was like yeah we're gonna have players
on campus and now we are having players
on campus but we're also seeing a lot of
positive tests we on our first game
canceled today an HBCU game that's been
played between Tennessee State Jackson
State in Memphis for the last thirty
years they're cancelling that game
scheduled for September 12th out of what
they said was Kovac 19 concerns and
problems number of positive cases is
increasing in a lot of areas we'll see
if there's a corresponding increase in
hospitalizations and in deaths but you
know I just think that this as this
thing has ebbed and flowed it's been
really hard to have a definitive answer
I think we will play on time I think
there will be little to no fans in
attendance but I even then you know I
still think if it's even if things are
full system go by July 1st August 1st
could tell a different story
September 1st could tell a different one
as well I guess if you think about it
Pat though the the sport that or the
sport and and level of sport that could
be most impossible to pull this off is
college football where you've got
hundreds right hundreds of schools
you've got hundreds of places you've got
places that may have certain protocols
in place you know in the Big Ten are
different from another conference that
comes into somebody's building and then
whatever conference bubble community
that could have been created gets
pierced on the spot vectors all over the
place you know the the Notre Dame
schedule is a perfect example where they
play it's it's like I say it's like a
United Nations of teams different
conferences different time zones all
over the place and maybe some
conferences are ready to go and other
conferences can't and then how in the
world does everybody play the same
schedule number of games
I mean your head spins when you think
about it but they have to financially
get going though right they can't just
forego and punt that would change the
finances of collegiate sports writ large
for years Pat right oh absolutely yes
from a financial economic standpoint
this season is must play now we'll see
if if health and safety concerns trump
that right but for now that's absolutely
the approach to that letter correct is
it taking like we've got to play
football you know will lose sports will
you know some schools may shut down not
necessarily just related to football but
you know if there's not fall semester
classes if there aren't people on campus
it's it's catastrophic for some
universities from an economic standpoint
and you are correct that there are more
complications and permutations related
because football than any other sport I
could imagine this [ __ ] 130 teams in
just an FBS alone all over the country
some here is the country being affected
much differently than others they are on
campuses with thousands of other
students all who you know most of them
come from all different places to get
there and then yeah you disperse to go
play a game and then you come back to
the same campus you know the means it's
gonna be really really really hard even
without throwing in the face to face
exertion of the sport itself and the
contact level of it you know right this
is stop so then I guess the final one
for you Pat is when do you think the go
no-go is gonna be I mean here we are in
the middle of June we are seeing the NBA
tried out but they're creating their own
campus or we'll call it a bubble they're
calling it a campus you know baseball
there's actually some news on the front
that I'm gonna get to in a second where
both sides are actually you know the
skies might be brightening just to slip
it but you've got um you know hockey's
gonna give it a whirl the NFL is only
got 32 teams so what what do you got for
me on a go/no-go do you think for
college football here oh yeah you know I
mean a lot of the people I talked to
we're happy to kick the can down the
road on dono go and I don't blame them
because they shoe it
you know and they kicked it til til June
one okay all right now we're gonna
players back on campus it's now middle
of June maybe by July 1 we got a better
feeling for how this is going
July 15th I would say we need to know
okay here's this yeah the schedule is
going to be played as it says or no it's
not so I would say maybe a month from
now okay uh you know we find out whether
we're at least starting on time there's
no telling whether we may be ending on
top Pat thanks for the time really
appreciate it and let's stay in touch
really appreciate your thoughts yep you
got it that's Pat 40 if Sports
Illustrated here in the Rich Eisen show
I said you know my bad on his latest
spot he was with Yahoo for a long I know
that it's I know that I know that and I
just had the Yahoo in my head from
Thomas Moore said and it's again a
silent exclamation point and it just
screws me up
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here